We have today one of those totally wacky
Trump stories that came out yesterday
where it would be hilarious if Trump wasn't
actually in charge of the nuclear codes.
And it is now being widely reported that Donald
Trump got bored earlier in his presidency
during a classified intelligence briefing. So he
interrupted the meeting to bring in a waiter to
order a milkshake, despite the waiter not being
cleared to be in the room or hear any of what was
being discussed. Trump just said, bring them over.
I want a milkshake. Imagine being this desperate
for a milkshake or this bored during high level
classified briefings that you have to you just
must get a milkshake right away. The scene is 2017
at Trump's New Jersey golf club. There is Trump's
they're having a meeting with the CIA Special
Activity Center. That's a unit that is responsible
for operations, including clandestine and covert
operations, where the U.S. government doesn't
want to be overtly associated. Like this is
really, really high level stuff, very classified
for lack of a better term. Trump interrupts
the meeting and says, does anybody want a malt?
That's how he refers to milkshakes, insists
the waiter at his golf club be brought in. We
have the best malts, he said to the people around
him. The waiter comes in and of course, it was an
immediate and early red flag to the intelligence
community, to the national security officials,
that this presidency may not go so well. And,
of course, it's gone very, very poorly since
then. When Trump said he'd hire the best people,
I guess he wasn't talking about national security
staff or campaign staff. I guess he met the
people that will bring them a milkshake at a
moment's notice. And this this puts satire out
of business. How do you make a parody of this
on Saturday Night Live? How do you create a
headline for The Onion? Because the real headline
is The Onion headline. It's no different. It's
all the same at this point in time. And I think
that it should worry us. It's amusing, but it
should worry us that when this story breaks,
no one doubts that it's something Trump would do.
Sure. You know, you'll have the regular defenders
of Trump say, oh, sources, you you can't what? Can
we really trust it? It's just too obvious that,
of course, Donald Trump would do something like
this and think about it from the other side. By
the way, imagine being an intelligence official.
You're in the middle of briefing Trump about some,
you know, a super high level covert operation. And
Trump interrupts and asks you if you want a malt
during a briefing. And actually, it is anybody
surprised that Trump asked anybody else if they
wanted a milkshake? Trump is so self-centered that
that piece is actually notable, although I'm sure
The View paid for that milkshake, if any
of those national security officials ended
up except accepting one through your tax
dollars. So I guess what we can say here is,
yeah, we have the opportunity to remove
him and very, very soon, a couple of weeks.
Can we be glad it wasn't Obama who did
it? Because if Barack Obama had ordered
a milkshake during such a meeting, it would
have been a 24/7 national security scandal.
Sean Hannity would have been talking about
it. Rush Limbaugh would've been talking
about it. Fortunately, it was only Trump. And
by the way, the really important takeaway on
briefings is it has been weeks since Donald Trump
received an intelligence briefing. He's held
must be like twelve rallies in the
last two weeks. He took a few days off,
but he had up to two and even three rallies on
some days. It's probably been a dozen rallies over
the last two weeks. And Trump has not actually
received a security briefing and intelligence
briefing for several weeks. That's the living
nightmare, which we absolutely have to end.